nueva redada policial en una favela de
río de janeiro que con 25 muertos se
convirtió en la mayor matanza en la
capital carioca en 16 años se trata de
la primera acción de este tipo desde que
el año pasado la corte suprema de
justicia suspendiera a las operaciones
policiales tras la muerte de al menos 65
personas durante el confinamiento el
resultado de esto es el fortalecimiento
del tráfico de drogas sin presencia
policial el tráfico de drogas gana poder
expande sus dominios y avanza cada vez
más en la sociedad la redada del jueves
buscaba desmontar un grupo de
narcotraficantes que actuaba en la
favela y reclutaba a menores según las
autoridades pero finalmente acabó en un
tiroteo con la policía algunos vecinos
denunciaron a ejecuciones por parte de
los uniformados algo que se negó desde
la institución policial
la única ejecución fue la de un oficial
de policía tristemente asesinado con
frialdad por los narcotraficantes oa la
cual reuters mucho las otras muertes
ocurrieron lamentablemente mientras los
narcotraficantes apuntaban a la policía
y luego fueron neutralizados
es así de simple esta mujer relata sin
embargo como la policía entró en su casa
y mató a uno de los supuestos
delincuentes sin mediar palabra donde no
dieron tiempo el joven de decir nada mi
única reacción fue proteger a mi familia
mi niña de nueve años vio todo nunca más
volverá a querer dormir en esa
habitación a mamá quiere dominen el
guaje human rights watch pidió una
investigación exhaustiva independiente
sobre las muertes según el organismo la
policía de río mató a 543 personas en lo
que va de año mientras que al menos
cuatro policías habrían fallecido en
acciones similares a la del jueves